the Mad thing is and I do feel bad for
saying this I actually really
ate baked beans I must be one of only
men in England or only person in England
that eats baked beans yeah why don't you
try just pouring it on and then like we
can go on let me uh
and what have we got here what's this oh
I've come to this in this section right
right
oh I can I eat beans you know what
for you lot though I will get a go it
must be 15 years since I've had some
beans I've been and then two cheese in
the other
both oh yeah yeah sorry
it's gonna be gross this
what do you like about them I don't know
they're just weird okay but these are
cold as well
oh it's been awful man
it's gross man